here with more author of the price of
principal great book by the way
harvard law professor alan dershowitz
along with the attorney for president
trump lindsey halligan is with us
lindsey i'll start with you tonight
is that in fact everything john reported
accurate
yes uh president trump to my
understanding declassified
everything um
the fbi's withholding of information and
lack of transparency is
is crazy it's honestly it may be the
first step to tyranny uh controlling the
channel of information is also part of
that and if it wasn't for truth social
twitter might have banned president
trump from telling the world what
happened on monday
seems that they want to silence
president trump and cancel his ability
to tell the truth
if you look at his track record he's
exposed them one spying on his campaign
to the corruption of hunter biden's
influence peddling for millions of
dollars
and three voter fraud uh the invention
of ballot drop boxes which the supreme
court just ruled unconstitutional and
now he's exposing the over range
overreach of monday's raid on mar-a-lago
we still don't know
what exact documents they took other
than
some mementos
yeah professor dershowitz let's get your
take on all of this and and very
specifically too
along with the classification issue the
espionage act section cited uh in the
warrant
well first of all if it is true that
these were declassified then the justice
department must immediately file an
amendment to its request for a search
warrant it must disclose this new
information to the judge unlike what
happened under the fisa where they
failed to disclose this new information
if in fact these materials were
declassified then the search warrant the
application for the search warrant and
the affidavit if it didn't include this
information it would have to be voidable
at this point and so that's the first
key
and there are so many other issues here
the espionage act as a civil libertarian
it was the worst act possible it was
used to go after dissidents it was used
to go after a previous presidential
candidate uh eugene v debs a socialist
civil libertarians hated this statute
the aclu was constantly
jumping up and down you can't use the
espionage statute it was used against
ellsberg everybody else
now the same people who oppose the
espionage statute are jumping up and
down saying wow we have the espionage
statute we can now get trump we might
not have been able to get him previously
but we're going to use this statute
which we hate and oppose for years to
try to get trump and we're going to try
to disqualify him because we're going to
amend the constitution and say the
criteria for president running for
office goes beyond the four criteria in
the constitution and congress can pass a
statute saying that if you're convicted
under a crime you can't now if that were
true then a democratic controlled
congress could disqualify a republican
like trump from running for reelection
so obviously that would be
unconstitutional so let me stay on one
let me focus in on one thing that you're
saying here
because the espionage
18 usc 793 that came up a lot with
hillary clinton it also came up with
sandy berger who actually went into the
national archives took documents shoved
him in his crotch and in his socks and
walked out with them and got a slap on
the wrist hillary clinton even james
comey admitted that in fact she had top
secret classified information on a
server that was hacked by foreign
entities but said yeah even though we
acknowledge the law was likely broken no
prosecutor would ever prosecute so now
we've got what do do we have equal
justice or not in this country professor
when an announcement of equal justice we
have the attorney general saying that
equality uh is the essence of the
justice department but then never
explaining why these espionage statutes
are used now they were never used
against burger and uh and certainly not
against clinton and uh the question is
do we really have equality or do do we
have a double standard of justice and it
seems to me that although garland says
we have equality his actions speak
louder than words and going after
president trump who i voted against i'm
a liberal democrat not a republican i
want to have the right to vote for him
or against him when he runs again i
don't want a bureaucrat making the
decision whether he should be allowed to
run so i don't think we have equal
justice today and i think every american
right or left republican or democrat
should be opposed to what's going on now
and demand that the standards that were
previously used continue to be used and
there not be any changes because
somebody is a republican rather than a
democrat equal protection of the law is
central
lindsey let me give you the last word
but also i want to ask you this question
when the president called for the
release of all documents is he also
calling for the release of the affidavit
and as it relates to
professor dershowitz's arguments based
on john solomon's report will the
president now act on that and demand
that the attorney general take the
action the professor mentioned
uh yes that
what president trump means by release
the documents is release the documents
stop hiding stuff
the attorneys
the attorneys have asked the department
of justice um over the phone many times
can you give us the full and complete
inventory of everything that was taken
from president trump's
house and they refused to give
a full list and what's interesting is
the warrant was executed on friday
and
if and they didn't they didn't raid the
place until monday and if the documents
that president trump had at his uh
property were so top secret so
classified and such a threat to national
security why did they wait two to three
days to uh break in it's a great if it
was about nuclear uh yeah you think they
would have acted sooner or the fbi and
the doj were there
um and i'm not sure if you were there uh
but i know others were and donald trump
said you're welcome any time come back
anytime you want is that true
that's the last thing that he said to
them when they were on his property he
said anything else you need just let us
know and the next time that they heard
from them was when they asked president
trump to turn off his video surveillance
before they started their search
but you still have control of that
surveillance uh video will you be
releasing it publicly
that's up to president trump
okay thank you ellen dershowitz lindsey
lindsey halligan thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else